All over the country,
statues of confederate generals
and other controversial historical figures
are being removed.
You've heard about this.
They're being removed,
or sometimes they're being torn down.
Now, most people are really glad
to finally see some of these statues gone.
But not everybody's onboard.
One of those people
is joining me via satellite.
Please welcome the Bob's Big Boy statue.
Ah, hey, hi, Conan.
Hello.
[Conan] Hey, well, thank
you so much for being here.
First off, how do I address you?
Is it Bob, or do I call you Big Boy?
(laughs) Yeah, well,
that's pretty confusing.
So Bob is my dad, and I'm his big boy.
So, but you know what?
Just call me Kevin.
It's less awkward.
Okay, great.
So Kevin,
how do you feel
about all of these
statues being taken down?
I'm terrified.
I've been sleeping with one eye open.
I may look like I'm smiling,
but inside I am crapping my overalls!
Well, oh, you know, you
shouldn't be scared.
I don't think you have
anything to worry about, Kevin.
You're just a fast food mascot.
Nothing to worry about?
Oh, trust me.
I know where this is going!
First, they come for the Confederates
then it's the slave owners.
Then it's probably gonna
be the lawn gnomes,
and then pretty soon
all of us fast food guys
are on the guillotine!
That's why I've been packin' heat, Conan!
Okay, no, no, no.
You shouldn't be packing heat.
Don't do that.
I'm armed to the teeth, Conan!
I'm ready to pop off!
I've got a walk-in gun closet!
Alright, okay, no.
[Kevin] I do!
I've got a desert eagle-
No, no.
[Kevin] hiding under the
pickles in this burger!
I do!
[Conan] Okay!
No, no, stop!
My pockets are stuffed with grenades!
Calm, down!
No, no, no, this whole
movement isn't about statues,
but about what kind of
people the statues represent!
I mean it's not like
you've done anything wrong.
Oh, no, Conan.
I've done terrible things.
Really?
Like what?
Off the record?
Well, no, this is a live TV show.
Thank you.
Where do I start?
Tax evasion, some light credit card fraud,
a ton of DUIs!
Okay, well, that's not good.
That's pretty bad,
but it's not as bad as some of the things
these statues have done.
Well, but I'm just getting started.
Selling human organs on the dark web,
cock fighting, and I mean both kinds.
I told Harvey Weinstein
to use that walker.
I wrote that song "Despacito"!
You wrote "Despacito"?
I did!
It was a moment of weakness!
I shouldn't have written
it let alone released it!
Oh god, okay.
You know what?
I'm, no, I'm not letting you off the hook.
I do hope someone tears you down then.
Well if they try,
they're gonna be ordering
a hot bullet combo meal to go!
I'm loco, Conan!
I'm crazy!
I will take you out!
(rumbling)
Oh! Oh!
Oh no!
No, they're here!
Oh, I knew it!
I'm going down, Conan!
Take him away guys.
So long, Kevin, and I won't
be sorry to see you go.
Delete my browser history,
and remember, we're open
for curbside pick up!
(Kevin's scream fades out)
(statue crashing)
Loyal to those burgers to the very end.
You gotta admire him.
Are you dead yet, Kevin?
(hammers banging)
[Kevin] Not yet.
They're pounding on me with glee!
They're going right for my eyes!
(statue crashing)
Is your body intact or
has that been smashed?
[Kevin] The body has been smashed!
People are crawling inside of me!
It's horrible!
Anyway, that was Bob's Big Boy,
a.k.a. Kevin.
He's been torn down.